AL PITTAMPALLI: Welcome,
everybody.
It's an honor to be here.
I wanted to start off
with this story.
Charles Duhigg has this great
story in his book "Power Of
Habit." It's about this guy.
You might recognize this guy,
because this is Paul O'Neill.
Paul O'neill was the former
Secretary of the Treasury.
But what you might not know is
before Paul O'Neill was the
Secretary of the Treasury, was
the president of a company
called Alcoa.
Alcoa is a big steel
manufacturer, and at the time,
when he first came on board,
Alcoa wasn't doing too well.
In fact, Alcoa was
floundering.
So Paul O'Neill was supposed to
be the guy who was going to
turn the entire thing around.
So at his very first investor's
meeting, investors
packed the room in high
anticipation, because they
wanted to know what this
guy had to say.
What was his plan?
He was supposed to be this
savior to right this sip.
So as Duhigg tells the
story, Paul O'Neill
comes up to the podium.
It's this really dramatic
moment, and the audience is
waiting with baited breath.
And Paul O'Neill says something
to this effect.
He says, "Ladies and gentlemen,
today I want to
talk to you about
worker safety.
Worker safety is going to be
the number one priority at
this company going forward."
And the audience is shocked.
They're like, what is this
guy talking about?
I mean, we have real
problems here.
We thought he was going to talk
about financials, and
profit margins, and bottom
line stuff, and here is
talking about something trivial
like worker safety.
So they challenged him.
They said, Paul, are you sure
you want to be talking about
worker safety right now?
And he says, I don't think you
understand me correctly.
Worker safety is going to be
the number one priority at
this company going forward.
And so the story goes, the
investors leave the room
thinking Paul O'Neill's crazy.
They're calling up their
clients, telling them to dump
the stock, and all
this mayhem.
So the question is, was
Paul O'Neill, in
fact, really crazy?
And the answer, if you
judge by results, is
a resounding no.
It turns out over the course
of his tenure, Alcoa
experienced amazing growth.
It was this remarkable
transformation story.
It's actually one of the reasons
he became tapped to
become the Secretary
of the Treasury.
So what did Paul O'Neill know
that no one else did?
Well, if you ask Charles Duhigg,
the answer is what he
calls the keystone habit.
What a keystone habit is, it's
a habit that when you change
it, it has cascading
effects and changes
other habits as well.
And what Paul O'Neill understood
about worker safety
is that when you fix worker
safety, when you work on
worker safety, there's all
these other things
that have to happen.
When you focus on worker safety,
in order for that to
be good, you got to have good
communication between the
staff and the managers.
In order for worker safety to
be good, you have to be
innovative, and good problem
solving, and pay attention to
detail and processes.
All things that are so
important for a steel
manufacturing company.
So Paul we understood that the
worker safety had this
disproportionate impact.
If they could focus on that,
they would create this
cascading effect across the
entire organization.
I tell you this story
for two reasons.
The first is because I think
meetings, like worker safety,
is the ultimate keystone
habit in organizations.
If you think about meetings,
what they are, they're at the
intersection of how we
communicate, how we
collaborate, how we make
decisions on the most
important issues of the day.
So when we talk about meetings,
it's not just these
30 minutes things that are on
our calendar that we attend
every single day.
What they are is an access
to changing the entire
organization, to change
the way we think and
the way we do business.
So I think that's important to
realize, and I do believe that
this culture gets this.
I mean, your CEO clearly
gets it.
Larry Page famously sent out
that memo when he first
started at Google, when he first
joined us the CEO, and I
think that this is a priority
of this company, so I really
feel privileged to
talk to you guys.
The second reason I've told
you this story is because
that's the approach I
want to take today.
Rather than giving you an
entire map of radical
overhaul, which sometimes and
often fails, what I want to do
is just give you three specific
habits, three
specific behaviors, that are
actionable, that seem almost
simplistic, but have the
potential to have
disproportionate impact.
By changing just these small,
little things, you'll create
cascading effects that might
actually change a lot of other
things, and ultimately
the culture.
So that's what I want to do.
I want to talk about these three
habits, but I also got
to talk about why I'm
prescribing these habits.
I want to talk about the
forces that cause
meetings to be broken.
So let's talk about the first
keystone habit, and then I'll
explain what it is or
why it's there.
We want to identify one decision
owner before any
decision-oriented meeting
convenes.
Sounds pretty simple.
The key word as "before,"
by the way.
And I'll explain that
in a moment here.
But the reason why this is so
effective and so important,
because it's so rarely done,
is because of something we
call diffusion of
responsibility.
This is my poster child for
diffusion of responsibility.
This is a picture of
Parkland Memorial
Hospital in Dallas, Texas.
One of the biggest hospitals
in the country.
Last year, Parkland had this
problem, which is they
needed a new CEO.
The past CEO had resigned.
They needed a new one
to take their place.
This is a pretty big decision
for an organization.
So Parkland did what
you'd imagine any
organization would do.
They called a meeting.
They got the entire board in a
room together, and they asked
this question, so what
are we going to do?
Now that seems like the
right approach, right?
It seems like the smart
thing to do,
but there was a problem.
45 minutes into the 90 minute
meeting, they had no idea why
they were in the room.
They had no idea what
they're deciding.
They had no idea what the
action items were.
So 45 minutes into the meeting,
somebody made a
suggestion.
They said, well, why don't we
hire an executive search firm?
Great idea.
They couldn't decide on
which firm to hire.
So someone else had
a brilliant idea.
They said, why don't we hire a
consultant to help us hire the
executive search firm?
You didn't hear this wrong.
They were thinking about hiring
a consultant to hire a
consultant, which I think is
absurd, but they thought it
was pretty good idea.
But they couldn't even decide
on what consultant to hire.
So what they did was they
ended up appointing a
subcommittee to come up with a
list of five candidates of
potential consultants
that would be
reviewed at the next meeting.
And this sounds funny, right?
Because it's absurd.
One of the things you can
do is you can blame the
individuals.
And trust me, I have.
You can blame the individuals
in that meeting and say
there's something
wrong with them.
But when you see this, like I
have, across so many different
organizations, all across the
country-- the world, even--
you realize that there's
something else going on here.
There's some social forces
at play here.
We know what some of the
social forces are.
The entire field of social
psychology is dedicated to
these phenomena.
Bibb Latane and John Darley did
these famous experiments--
you probably know about them--
50 years ago.
They were called smoke filled
room experiments.
They'd get students into a room
together to take a test.
The test was a guise, because
really what they did was they
were pumping smoke into the room
while they were taking
the test, trying to figure out
how long it would take them to
report what was supposed
to look like a fire.
When they had one student in the
room, what they found was
the performance was fine.
One person in room, about 75% of
the time or so, you got to
students report the fire in
a really timely basis.
What happens when you put just
two more people into the room?
Performance drops
dramatically.
You go from 75% of the time to
38% of the time students
report the fire.
Almost a comical effect.
You have the students with smoke
filling their eyes, and
they're crying, and they're
still not reporting this fire.
And so we learn something from
that experiment, which is that
groups are really good at
solving problems, but that is
not without exception.
When responsibility is
ambiguous, groups can actually
perform abysmally, particularly
when we don't
understand what the decision is,
what we're deciding, who
should be deciding.
Think about what we do so
often in organizations.
Whenever there's a problem,
whenever there's ambiguity on
what we should be doing, we get
into a room together and
try to sort it all out.
And that's precisely what
the diffusion of
responsibility wants.
It magnifies the effect, so we
end up doing nothing, or it
ends up taking a
very long time.
Now if we drill down on this,
what we realize that one of
the primary, driving
forces behind
this is social etiquette.
We all have these social
boundaries around us.
We hate breaking them.
You walk into an elevator,
everybody's
facing in one direction.
You don't dare face
the other way.
We know this.
In organizations that have clan,
communal cultures, flat
organizational structures, we
find this even more present,
where everybody's equal
so it's hard to
really impose yourself.
It's hard to own up
to a decision.
It's hard to take responsibility
because we're
afraid of infringing on other
people's territory and stuff.
So what are the consequences
of this?
Well.
We get massive delay.
A decision that should
take five
minutes takes five months.
A decision that's supposed
to take one meeting
ends up taking 10.
We also get compromise, which
sometimes is good, but in a
world that's blending all
together, compromise decisions
often get ignored.
Designed by committee often
leads to horrible things that
we don't want.
So we need to figure out how we
can solve this diffusion of
responsibility problem.
Well, what we know is that
leadership is the antidote to
the bystander effect, and that's
why decision owner is
so important.
When someone stands up, it
breaks the force field.
We all know, for example, when
you're on a subway car, and
there's a panhandler, and they
might do a good performance.
And everybody wants to give, but
nobody does because nobody
else is giving.
We all know what happens
when one person gives.
When one person gives, the force
field is broken, and
then everyone gives.
By the way, panhandlers have
gotten really smart.
If they worked in pairs, they
get a confederate to be the
first one that gives, and
that starts the process.
Well, we can do the same thing,
and that's why this
idea of making sure that we
have a decision owner-- an
explicit decision owner--
before we get into the room
has cascading effects.
If we have a decision owner,
we have accountability.
If we have accountability,
we're going
to clarify the decision.
If we clarify the decision,
then we know what decision
we're making, and we can
actually make it.
And the key word here, like I
alluded to before, is the word
"before." It has to happen
before we get into the room,
because if we wait until we get
into the room to decide
who's the decision owner, we're
already in the matrix.
We've already lost the game,
because we've already
succumbed to the diffuse
of responsibility.
The second keystone habit that
I want to talk about is this
idea of replacing meetings
with the one-on-one
conversations.
Not all meetings, by the way.
But I don't even call one-on-one
conversations
"meetings." I think they're
fundamentally different than
what we traditionally
think of as meeting.
So what's the impetus
for this?
Well, it's this idea that--
some of you are probably
familiar with this-- it's the
idea of the tragedy
of the commons.
Tragedy of the commons
is a parable which
I'll share with you.
Eight farmer's share
this plot of land.
That's how they make
their livelihood.
They allow the cows to
graze, and that's how
they make their living.
Well, these farmers have it
short term problem and a long
term problem.
Long term problem is obvious.
If too many cows are allowed to
graze the grass, then the
grass is ruined for everyone,
and no former wants that.
But there's the short term
problem faced by each
individual farmer.
It's a little bit less obvious,
but it's actually
more interesting.
And that individual
dilemma is this.
If I'm one of the farmers, I'm
thinking to myself, well, I
know I'm not supposed to have
one more cow in the grass, but
if I did, I would get all the
benefits of that cow, but
everybody else would have
to share the cost.
That asymmetry is a pretty
irresistible deal, and so what
happens is farmers
end up taking it.
And if one farmer does it,
every farmer does it.
And so what ends up happening
is one, two, three more cows
for every one, and the reason
why the tragedy of the commons
is a tragedy is because farmers
end up working in
their selfish, short term
interest at the expense of the
long term interests
of the group.
Now this is a widely known
social phenomenon.
We see this in overfishing.
We see this in pollution.
I would argue we see this
right here in the
organization.
Because if you think about how
a meeting works so often,
let's say I call a meeting of
eight people for one hour,
well, I get eight hours of
productivity from the people
in that room, and I only have
to spend one hour myself.
That's a pretty irresistible
deal.
It's one that's easy
to exploit.
I'm not saying that people
do is intentionally or
nefariously, but it happens,
and we have to realize that
that is going to create
a problem.
It's going to create a system
where you have tons and tons
of meetings, and that's
what happens.
I call it the tragedy
of the calendar.
That's why I talk to
organizations all the time,
and this is what people's
calendars look like, and it's
largely because this
phenomena.
I think that one of the reasons
the justification for
this is something that
isn't talked about.
Especially in hierarchical
organizations, it's almost assumed.
And I think we should talk
about the justification
because I think it's
a justification.
I don't think it makes
mathematical sense.
And what that justification
is, is if you're in a big
organization, the people higher
up the food chain will
say, hey, listen--
off the record, they
say, well, listen.
My time is extremely valuable.
and I need to do
this sometimes.
If it takes me five hours
to write a memo, that's
not good for me.
It might be advantageous for the
organization if I can get
people in a room together
and use their
time instead of mine.
They won't say it that way,
but that's kind of the
implicit justification.
And I'm going to argue that
that is the wrong
justification, because
let's look at the
extreme of that example.
Who has the most expensive
time in the world?
Who's got the move valuable
I would argue it's
the President
of the United States.
It turns out that the President
of the United
States, every morning since, I
think, 1947, has received this
report, which is the President's
Daily Briefing.
It's a report of the day's
intelligence, and this report
corresponds with the meeting
that follows it.
Most of the time.
Most times, you have a meeting
that follows it where you
discuss the report.
Well, there's one present a
particular, which is the
George W. Bush--
I'm not picking on anybody
politically here, but this
happens to be factual--
that George W. Bush didn't
want to read the memo
beforehand.
He actually showed up to the
meeting and preferred that he
be briefed in person.
So the first 15, 20 minutes of
the meeting or so was spent
actually, orally briefing the
President on what was already
in this memo.
You think to yourself, if
anybody could justify this,
it's the President of
the United States.
It's the person who's got the
most valuable time in the
world where we're trying
to maximize his time.
But then you think
to yourself, who
else is in that meeting?
And it turns out the other
people in that meeting are the
top of the top CIA officials,
Top of the CIA, and Department
of Defense.
I mean, these are the people
that have the second most
valuable time in the world.
And that's why this
justification doesn't work,
because if you think about
relatively speaking, the
people we have meetings with
are people who have similar
valuable time as we do.
So the consequences of this is
you get, like we said, tons of
meetings that are
often one sided.
You go into a meeting sometimes,
you feel like, wow,
that was a waste of my time.
And you were right, because
it was intended that way.
And we need to fix this.
We need to stand up and realize
that although this
happens, and implicitly, it's
not the way that an
organization should run.
So the question is,
how do we fix it?
Well, in the example of the
tragedy of the commons with
the farmer parable, one of the
things you can do is you
separate the plot of land into
eight separate plots, because
what you're trying to do is
you're trying to fix this
asymmetry problem.
If each individual farmer has
his own plot, what happens is
that every cow now that I let
onto the grass, I get all the
benefits, but I also
share the costs.
Well, what's the equivalent
in the organization?
Well, the answer is the
one-on-one conversation.
The one-on-one conversation's
an amazing tool, because
unlike a meeting, it's
really personal.
It's direct.
It's free from group think.
But the other great thing about
a conversation is it's
beautifully symmetrical.
I spend one hour, you
spend one hour.
And this reduces the incentives
of the meeting, or
the tragedy of the
commons effect.
So I think we need to switch to
one-on-one conversations as
the primary fuel.
Not to say that we can do
everything that way, but a lot
of meetings we can do as
one-on-one conversations.
And that produces amazing,
cascading effects because when
you use one-on-one
conversations, you're forced
to think really hard about
who you're having these
conversations with.
Because now instead of using the
meeting as this weapon of
mass interruption, where you
get eight people in a room
together and it's easy for you,
try having the eight one
hour conversations
with people.
It's not as easy.
So there's friction.
It improves the quality of the
conversations, and it reduces
the quantity.
And that creates a culture
that's free from interruption,
or where there's less
interruption.
Final keystone habit, and then
I want to move into the
question and answer.
Make all standing meetings
tentative.
So what that means is that
any standing meeting, any
regularly occurring meeting,
does not exist unless we
initiate it every single time.
I'll concede that sometimes
maybe you want to have a
regular meeting, and you can
carve out time with your team
where there might
be a meeting.
But every week before
that meeting meets,
it's got to be initiated.
The default should
be no meeting.
And the reason why this is
so crucial, and why this
specific, small habit has
disproportionate impact, is
something I call meeting
institutionalization.
The meeting has become
this institution.
A great example is with NASA.
I did some work with NASA, who
were brilliant, by the way,
and great folks.
But one of the groups I worked
with, they have this meeting
that they have every
single week.
It's called the ICB meeting.
The Internal Control
Board meeting is
what they call them.
And it's a very important
thing.
They spend a lot of time making
sure that we're talking
about the right things,
but there's
problems with that meeting.
They go on too long.
There's too many things
that are discussed.
And I interviewed some
people beforehand.
I said, what's the purpose
of this meeting?
And no one can really give
me a clear answer.
They say, well, it changes all
the time, and it's kind of
difficult to explain.
And then I said, well, if you
don't know what the purpose
is, why don't you
get rid of it?
And the gasped.
I mean, they almost threw
me out of the room.
I'm kidding, they're
wonderful people
But they couldn't even fathom
the idea of getting rid of
this thing.
I'm not saying they
should have.
I just said, why don't
you consider it?
And the reality is it was clear
to me that this meeting
was no longer a meeting.
It was an institution.
See, the meeting is supposed
to be this tool, right?
You start out with a problem,
and you say, OK, is the
meeting the right tool
to fix this problem?
Maybe it's email.
Email is another tool.
But that's not what happens
very often.
What happens often is we start
with the meeting, and we say,
OK, what problems do we
fix at the meeting?
That's what was happening
with the Internal
Control Board meeting.
Every week they had this
question, which is what do we
need to talk about
at this meeting?
And this backwards
justification
creates a lot of problems.
It creates what I call
the CNN problem.
CNN has this problem.
They need 24 hours of
news every single
day, no matter what.
What happens on the day where
there is no news?
That's when you see stories
about cats.
[LAUGHTER]
AL PITTAMPALLI: The stories
about otters that they taught
to play basketball.
Which is adorable, by the
way, but it's not news.
But that's what happens when
the meeting becomes an
institution and you
backwards justify.
You end up talking about trivial
things or things that
you wouldn't otherwise talk
about if you had started the
other way around.
Now the interesting thing is
this is not a phenomenon we
see, for example, in email.
Email's another tool, but we
don't see this phenomenon
really often in email.
And I think the reason
is because meetings
are a social event.
And social events get
ritualized, and if you're not
careful, they get
institutionalized.
A great example of this is
the State of the Union.
Which I love, by the way.
I mean, I'm a geek, I
love watching the
State of the Union.
But the reality is most people
don't know that before the
State of the Union was
this big, live
address, it was a memo.
For the longest amount of time,
the President wrote the
State of the Union, and he
sent it out to Congress.
And somewhere along the way--
I forget when it was, I think
50 or 60 years ago-- they
started doing it at
this live address.
It was easy to go from that
memo to meeting, but it's
almost impossible to go from the
meeting back to the memo.
Because now when you think of
State of the Union, it's
synonymous with meeting.
We can't even think of
the State of the
Union without the meeting.
If you propose to somebody, you
say, hey, maybe we should
go back to a memo, they're going
to think that you are
committing treason.
They think that you want to get
rid of the State of the
Union altogether, because they
can't fathom it as a memo.
And that's what happens when
the meeting becomes
institutionalized, and we have
to be careful of that.
So the reason why we want to
make all standing meetings
tentative is because we want
to start the process of
deinstitutionalizing
the meeting.
This is just one small way to do
it, because if every single
week, like if it's a weekly
meeting, and every single week
somebody has to initiate
the meeting--
it's on the calendar, but unless
somebody stands up and
says, we should have this
meeting, it doesn't exist--
well, then you have
this problem.
Which is somebody has to put
themselves on the line, and
somebody has to justify this
meeting's existence every
single time.
It may be a formality.
You may still have
the meeting.
But at least you have some
accountability, and you have
this sense that there is a
purpose to this meeting.
A meeting is a form, it's
not a function.
So these are the three
keystone habits.
They're not the only habits, but
they're a really great way
to make a huge dent
in the culture.
Because remember, all that
culture is, is it's a
collection of habits.
It's a collection of the way
people think and the way
people behave.
And the greatest thing, I think,
about meetings is that
they're the perfect
marketing tool.
It's a viral phenomenon.
You cannot have meetings
without other people.
It sounds daunting to change an
entire department or entire
organization, but just focus on
your corner of the world.
Focus on meetings
that you have.
Focus on the meetings
that you attend.
Try to change those, because
if you do, there's a chance
that it might spread.
And when habits spread, that's
how cultures change.
Well, thank you to listen to the
presentation part of this.
I'd love to take
some questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sometimes the
difficulty is in trying to get
a decision maker in the room.
For whatever reason, they're not
available, or originally
they said they would make it,
and they can't make it, or
something like that.
How do you address that?
AL PITTAMPALLI: Well, I think
that's why making it explicit
is really important.
First of all, let's distinguish
decision maker
form decision owner.
I like the term "decision owner"
because it implies that
that person could be the
decision maker, but he doesn't
necessarily have to be
a decision maker.
So for example, I know one of
the Google creeds is to strive
for consensus, which is
important, and I think that's
usually a good thing.
So a decision owner can say,
I'm not the decision
maker in this case.
What I am is I'm kind
of the conduit.
We're going to decide this
by group consensus.
And if a consensus can't be
reached, then I become the
unilateral decision maker.
The other thing about decision
owner is there's
no bones about it.
You own the decision.
It's kind of this territorial
phenomenon
that is really important.
And the reason why making it
explicit is really important
is because as soon as you become
the decision owner, you
can't even dream of not being
at the meeting where this is
being talked about.
Because you're the decision
owner, how are
you not at that meeting?
So it's this framing problem
that we're creating for that
person, and so way before the
decision even happens, we need
to figure out, OK,
who is the owner?
Who's a person, for all intents
and purposes, is
responsible for making
this decision?
Which is a great time to talk
about it, because the further
you are away from the actual
decision, the less anxious
people are, the less afraid
people are of taking
responsibility.
So if you catch people in the
very beginning and make sure
that they sign their name as a
decision owner, well, now you
have some accountability, it's
going to be way easier to get
that person involved.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What are your thoughts
on the value that--
like for example, my team
[INAUDIBLE] we just talk about
[INAUDIBLE], and there's
often [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
why not somebody else
[INAUDIBLE] something that
[INAUDIBLE]
the idea of always
[INAUDIBLE].
AL PITTAMPALLI: Well,
there's two things.
The first is I think that those
type of typical kind of
staff status meetings, we might
call them or something,
the one thing that's
clear to me is that
they should be optional.
I understand there's value to
these types of meetings, but
as we learn from, for example,
Susan Cain's book, "Quiet,"
that there are different
type of people.
There are introverts, there
are extroverts.
People are creative differently,
people are
productive differently.
An introvert, for example,
might not want
to attend the meeting.
Maybe it might be more
beneficial for them just to
stay in their pod and just do
work during that time and not
be interrupted.
And so I don't know if it's
beneficial to force people to
come to the meeting if they
don't want to be there, so I
think the first step is
to make them optional.
Because the reality is whether
we force people or not, the
presumption in organizations,
the implicit contract, is
you're coming to the meeting.
If I invite you, you
got to come.
It's almost like being
subpoenaed
to testify in court.
It's like punishable
by jail time.
That's usually the kind of
ethos in an organization.
The other thing is
I agree that--
this is kind of an indirect way
to answer your question--
which is that the term
"collaboration" is almost
meaningless now.
It's virtually a meaningless
word because we don't know
exactly what we mean or
what we talk about.
one of people's objections is
always, well, meetings are a
great collaborative tool.
Now you come into a room, you
rub elbows with people,
there's all these ideas, and
there might be some type of
spark of inspiration, or
creativity, or some overlap
that will get us for me
to be more productive.
And that's valid.
That's a valid concern, but
there's millions of different
types of collaboration.
There's indirect collaboration
where you go into a room, and
you brainstorm, and somebody
kind of gets
some idea out of something.
But then there's the direct
collaboration where you go
into room, and like a writer
and an editor, you give
somebody an idea, and you say,
hey, what's my feedback on
this
I guess what I'm saying-- this
is a circuitous way of
saying-- that we need to figure
out what exactly we're
aiming for here.
So if you invite people into a
status meeting for the hope
that there's going to be some
collisions, there might be
better ways to do that.
I mean, an asynchronous
collaboration tool in the
cloud, which you guys are
really good at, that
oftentimes yields more of those
types of collisions.
Sometimes it can be the
in-person meetings.
I don't know.
But the answer is we have to
design these meetings and
these sessions with a purpose
in mind, and the accidental
phenomenon I don't think is a
really good justification
because there's always
an opportunity cost.
It's a really expensive way
to deal with some of these
problems, so you've got
to just do a kind of a
cost-benefit analysis.
AUDIENCE: How do you feel about
letting people from
doing stuff on their laptops
during meetings?
AL PITTAMPALLI: I think that
all laptop should be out of
the room, unless there's
a real specific--
I mean, you guys are obviously
technology companies, so you
guys may take notes on laptops
and stuff like that, so for
this culture, that might
be kind of heresy.
For example, I did a training
for some folks at one of these
Fortune 500 organizations.
And I had a little tray outside,
and before they came
in, we literally confiscated
their phones, and their
laptops, and all their
electronic devices.
And I can get away with that
because that's kind of my
shtick and stuff.
I'm not saying that's exactly
what you should be doing, but
you should think about it.
Because one of the things that
does is it sends a signal.
It may do nothing else but just
send a signal that this
is a different type
of meeting.
When you come into this room,
we're actually going to do
business, we're going to talk
about important stuff, we're
not going to get distracted, and
the goal is to get out of
this room as quickly
as possible.
If we can do this in 20 minutes
instead of 60 minutes,
let's do it.
And so one of the things I think
we need to do as meeting
facilitators and leaders is send
these signals to people
to make sure that they
understand that this is a
different type of meeting.
And so that's kind of
one way to do that.
But if it's not a problem,
it's not a problem.
If it is, you know,
confiscate.
AUDIENCE: Do you make any kind
of distinction between
meetings and brainstorming
sessions which, you know, you
get an email like, hey, all
get into this room and
brainstorm about this.
And of course it looks exactly
like a meeting [INAUDIBLE]
is.
[INAUDIBLE] something different,
but a lot of times,
because there's no owner of
the brainstorming session
[INAUDIBLE] any kind of
[INAUDIBLE] just, bleh.
AL PITTAMPALLI: It's
a great question.
I realize I'm supposed to be
repeating these questions.
He asked about the difference
between a meeting and a
brainstorm.
One of the things that I think
we've failed at is to
distinguish different
types of meetings.
Just like I said that
collaboration, that word is
virtually meaningless, so is
the word "meeting." We call
everything a meeting.
I mean, is this a meeting?
I went to one of these
conferences they spoke at and
like a lot of people at it.
They call those meetings.
The people who plan
those meetings are
called meeting planners.
So we just have this horrible
vocabulary when it comes to
meetings, so one of the
things I do my book--
not enough of, but I
do it in my work--
is distinguishing what are
these different type of
sessions called, and what are
the corresponding purposes?
So when you think about
brainstorms, for example,
brainstorms are very different
than what I would think of as
a traditional meeting.
I think meetings are
about reducing
and coming to decisions.
Brainstorms are the opposite.
They're about imagination and
actually generating a lot of
possibilities and options.
But to your point, if I'm
walking down the hall, and I
see in the conference room, I
can't tell whether you're
doing a meeting or
a brainstorm.
That's a problem.
One of the corollaries to that
is that when we think about
problem solving, we
usually try to do
both at the same time.
Like if you're a writer, for
example, and you're a
productive writer, every
productive writer usually
knows that you can't write and
edit at the same time.
If you try to come up with a lot
of stuff and edit at same
time, you're going to
end up with nothing.
But that's how we approach
problem solving a lot times.
We try to come up with a lot
of options, and at the same
time we try to delete them.
So I say let's have the
brainstorm, the first part of
the problem solving, phase where
you just generate a lot
of options, and then the second
phase is the meeting
where we traditionally
reduce the options
and come to a decision.
It doesn't always work that
clean, but we should ideally
separate those two.
And we should organize the
session in a way that lends
itself to those things.
So if we organize a brainstorm,
we should make
sure that people are active.
Take a page from IDEO.
IDEO's the best brainstorming
company
in the world, arguably.
You guys might be the second,
third, I don't know.
What they do is they have
Post-its all over the place.
They're active, they're up,
they're all over the place.
Just visually, if you look at
what they're doing, it's just
very different than what most
of corporate America does.
So I think let's not even call
them the same thing.
Let's distinguish the two and
organize them in a way that
serves their function.
AUDIENCE: Sort of on that same
point further, sometimes
there's value in holding certain
types of meetings in
other places.
So if this is a conference room
where we have certain
types of meetings, like a
brainstorming session might
always be done in a different
kind of room, a specific place
where people sort of mentally
attach, that that's where you
to brainstorm.
Maybe it's all whiteboards
or--
AL PITTAMPALLI: Yeah.
I think that's absolutely
right.
Basically you're trying to get
people to stop filtering.
We're filtering every single
day, in every single meeting.
We're watching what we say.
We're watching what
we even think.
And so anything you can do to
anchor people to a different
emotional state is
really good.
That's why offsites
work really well.
You take somebody up to a
resort or a cabin in the
county, they're probably going
to be more creative because
the culture's different, the
environment is different.
I mean, we can't always go to an
offsite, but we can do that
in the organization.
We can have a separate room
dedicated to brainstorming.
We can organize the
room differently.
These are all things that really
promote creativity.
I believe that.
AUDIENCE: I think to follow up
a little bit on what you said
about bringing laptops to
meetings, I sometimes find
that if I'm invited to say, an
hour long sync up meeting that
is maybe two minutes [INAUDIBLE]
actually have
anything to do with me.
But rather than like-- there's
like social pressure to go.
So I would typically rather
bring my laptop and continue
to do work, and wait for someone
to say something that
has something to do with me
rather than not show up to the
meeting at all.
I'd like to hear your
thoughts about that.
AL PITTAMPALLI: I think that's
justified, but let's get to
the root of the problem.
Why are you in the meeting
to begin with?
Let's get you out
of the meeting.
Like if you don't need
to be there, then you
shouldn't be there.
You should be productive
by yourself.
There's great article--
maybe some of you have read
it-- by Paul Graham.
He founded Y Combinator.
He's big in the startup world.
And he wrote this article called
"The Difference Between
Managers Versus Makers, And
Why Meetings Are So
Contentious." I'm getting
some head nods here.
Because managers and makers have
just these two completely
different world views when
it comes to meetings.
Manager's days are broken up
into kind of hourly slots
because they're used to
going from meeting
to meeting to meeting.
So they're used to
the meetings.
They probably even
enjoy meetings.
Makers, on the other hand--
programmers, engineers, artists--
they don't work that way.
They need long stretches of
time to do their work.
So when they get invited to a
meeting, it's like you've shot
their entire day.
One meeting, 30 minutes,
and their entire day's
productivity is lost.
And a manager doesn't understand
that because they
don't share that world view.
So it's important, I think, in
organizations, in competitive
organizations, to realize that
we need to make sure that we
fill that communication gap.
Because in a world where makers
are so important-- we
need creativity, we need
productivity--
and people are just willfully
going to these meetings even
though they're not being
productive, we
need to stop that.
We need to start organizing
our work habits in a very
different way.
A manager might need to start
having simple, one-on-one
conversations with their
engineers and their
programmers.
Maybe they have office hour.
Maybe it's an office hours
format where between 2:00 and
4:00, you can stop in any
time you want for 10
minutes with that.
I don't know what the
answer is, but the
first step is the dialogue.
Unless we talk about this--
and I know it's tough, because
there are our bosses and the
people above us-- but there are
companies that are doing
it, and they're winning
because they're
changing the culture.
And so, we need to
do that too.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: What about quarterly
status updates?
Things that are, first of all,
very virtualized and must
happen every quarter, and some
manager organizes an entire
agenda which involves basically
presentations to the
organization and at the
beginning of the quarter, it
seems as though these
happen on every
level of the hierarchy.
So, yeah, the first week or two
of the quarter is lost to
these meetings.
AL PITTAMPALLI: The question
was about quarterly status
meetings, and I'm very skeptical
of any meeting that
meets with regularity.
Because again, a meeting is
supposed to be designed as a
tool to fix a problem.
A regular meeting presupposes
that there's some type of
problem that just comes up
consistently every single
quarter for some reason,
and I don't know
that to be the case.
I'm not saying we shouldn't have
them, but the first thing
we should do is be skeptical
of them, and say, well, why
exactly is that there?
And we need to work backwards.
We need to say, OK, well,
what is this for?
Not backwards, forwards.
We need to figure out what's
the problem, what are we
trying to solve, and is this
the right way to do it?
What exactly is this
status meeting for?
I mean, presentations, there's
lots of ways to do
presentations.
You guys have pioneered
some of them.
You can videotape it, you can
put it on YouTube, and you can
sent it out to everyone.
One of the reasons why we do
presentations in front of
everybody is to make sure
everybody comes, because we're
afraid if we do a presentation
online, and they don't watch
it, or they're not going
to watch it.
And that's a band aid.
There's some fundamental problem
if people aren't
watching the presentation.
Just forcing people into
a room to watch your
presentation is not
a good practice no
matter where you are.
So again, I think that whenever
there's some type of
meeting with some type of
regularity, we should be
suspicious.
We can really try to figure out
what the meeting is for,
and if there's no good
purpose, then we
should just not do it.
OK, well, listen, I really
am honored to
have spoken here today.
I'll be around for a little
while, so if you have any
questions, I'd love
to answer them.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]